si vous voulez apprendre le piano vous
vous remettre au piano j'ai une solution
à vous montrer qui est super
intéressante venez voir ça peut être
piano LED c'est une boîte française qui
fait ça en fait vous avez toute une
petite bandelette qui vient se mettre
derrière et grâce à son boîtier elle
vient se connecter sur votre piano ça
veut dire quoi ça fait quoi ça fait que
si vous touchez une touche vous allez
avoir la lumière LED correspondante et
quel que soit vos touches par exemple
ici je vais venir travailler un morceau
alors il m'attend j'appuie et ensuite je
vais venir suivre donc là vous voyez je
suis les petites notes directement donc
en fait le but ici c'est d'essayer
d'apprendre de pouvoir travailler les
morceaux ça c'est très pratique si vous
avez déjà fait du piano que vous voulez
vous en mettre c'est facile si vous
voulez débuter c'est extrêmement facile
vous êtes pris par la main et puis si
vous avez une prof un ou une prof qui
vous donne des cours et bien avec le
même système elle va pouvoir venir
enregistrer des exercices et vous allez
pouvoir les reproduire grâce à la
lumière LED directement ici la boîte
s'appelle piano LED allez sur Google
chercher vous allez pouvoir venir
acheter cette solution elle est super
intéressante pour vous mettre au piano
d'ailleurs dites-moi si vous êtes
musicien musicien en herbe ça pourrait
vous intéresser marquez moi ça dans les
commentaires